la mia infanzia spensierata definita in
un momento preciso che ricordo
nitidamente era il 1984
avevo 8 anni ed era ora di pranzo ero
appena uscito dall'ospedale di pordenone
con mia mamma ed ero super affamato
siamo entrati in un bar e appena entrati
ho visto questa fila di panini
buonissimi nella vetrina e così ho
chiesto a mia mamma se potevo avere un
panino con il prosciutto crudo e lei
l'ho notato subito ha cominciato a
guardare tutti i cartellini dei prezzi
dei panini e poi mi ha chiesto sicuro
che non ne vuoi uno con il prosciutto
cotto
io devo avere un po insistito però poi
ho visto lo sguardo di mia mamma mentre
preoccupata frugava nella borsa la
ricerca del portafoglio e lì in quel
preciso istante ho capito due cose
fondamentali e ho preso due fondamentali
decisioni
la prima quel giorno avrei mangiato un
panino con il prosciutto cotto e la
seconda è che non avrei mai più chiesto
niente di non necessario ai miei
genitori
facciamo un salto in avanti 2014 30 anni
dopo non più pordenone ma roma avevo 38
anni e sentivo di aver raggiunto tutto
quello che desideravo mi mantenevo
scrivendo film serie televisive
vivevo in una delle città più belle del
mondo e aveva un bel po di soldi in
tasca
che cosa volere di più niente il
problema però era che alla mattina mi
svegliavo e non volevo affrontare la
giornata
e così vomitavo c'era qualcosa che non
andava
non ero felice è il problema era che non
riuscivo a capire la natura di quel
malessere sin da piccolo le storie mi
hanno affascinato e sapevo che un giorno
raccontarle sarebbe diventato il mio
lavoro
e così ho cominciato a studiarle ci sono
moltissime teorie sullo storytelling
ma se volessimo sintetizzare potremmo
dire che raccontiamo sempre e solo la
stessa storia
e sì perché tutte le storie
di fatto lo stesso andamento questo ogni
volta che raccontiamo una storia
raccontiamo di un protagonista che vive
nel suo mondo ordinario
possiamo dire che sopravvive più o meno
felice poi a un certo punto succede
qualcosa
sua moglie lo lascia vince 100 milioni
alla lotteria o magari assiste ad un
omicidio
insomma qualcosa che potenzialmente può
cambiargli la vita ea quel punto entra
in un mondo che possiamo definire
sconosciuto e all'interno di questo
mondo dove inizia la sua avventura
incontra mentori amori antagonisti e
sale questa montagna fino ad arrivare in
cima
il meet point la falsa vittoria qui il
protagonista si convince di aver
raggiunto il suo obiettivo
ma la verità è che questo è il punto che
precede la catastrofe
da qui in avanti infatti l'antagonista
prende letteralmente a calci il nostro
protagonista fino a farlo a ruzzolare
giù dalla montagna e fino a farlo
arrivare in questa buca che ha un nome
terrificante il punto di morte
questo è il momento dove di solito tutto
sembra perduto ma la verità è che se
siamo di fronte ad una storia ben
raccontata
questo è anche il momento nel quale il
protagonista si volta indietro si rende
conto di quello che ha fatto durante
questa storia
durante questa avventura in questo mondo
sconosciuto quello che ha imparato e a
quel punto si rialza pronto ad
affrontare la sua battaglia finale il
suo vero obiettivo
sì perché tutte le storie hanno un
obiettivo
e sapete qual è l'obiettivo di ogni
storia il cambiamento
e sì perché ogni protagonista all'inizio
della storia a quello che viene definito
un fatal flow una ferita e affrontando i
propri demoni riesce a curarla quella
ferita e se ci riesce quando ci riesce
torna al suo mondo ordinario finalmente
in pace con se stesso
finalmente felice bello no eh sì lo è le
storie ci affascinano da sempre e da
sempre non possiamo farne a meno
perché le storie ci parlano di noi di
chi siamo
e soprattutto ci danno la forza di
cambiare o almeno di provare a farlo
le storie sono come la vita è adesso
vorrei fare un piccolo esperimento
prendiamo lo schema che abbiamo imparato
a conoscere e proviamo a sostituire ai
minuti di un film o alle pagine di un
romanzo gli anni di una vita e vedrete
che alla fine i conti tornano
allo stesso modo o almeno così è
successo per me e ora ve lo racconto i
primi 20 anni della mia vita il mio
mondo ordinario
li ho passati in friuli leggendo
centinaia di libri durante gli anni
della scuola e poi lavorando sui giorni
su 7
dopo le superiori e poi il mio incidente
scatenante nel mio caso un vero e
proprio incidente in macchina e così
quando la mia macchina è atterrata in un
campo e ho capito che sarebbe potuta
andare veramente molto molto peggio
mi sono chiesto ma se fossi morto adesso
saresti morto felice è la risposta
scontata è stata no quindi contro tutto
e tutti
lascia il friuli e vado a studiare prima
a torino e poi a roma e piano piano
salvo quella montagna e arrivò fino al
mio bit point alla mia falsa vittoria vi
ricordate quando vi ho detto che ogni
personaggio al suo fatta al flora sua
ferita
ecco per me quella ferita probabilmente
erano i soldi avevo paura di non averne
mai abbastanza
avevo paura che senza i soldi la mia
vita non sarebbe stata vissuta al
massimo
insomma c'ero riuscito ero in cima alla
montagna ed ero addirittura riuscito a
comprare una casa i miei genitori per
ringraziarli di tutti i sacrifici che
avevano fatto per crescere cinque figli
ma ve l'ho già detto non ero felice
i conti non tornavano per la mia vita
eppure tornavano perfettamente per le
regole dello storytelling e così poco
prima di compiere 40 anni cominciano gli
schiaffi in faccia le serie tv che
scrivo sono degli insuccessi uno dei
migliori amici muore in un attentato
mio padre è malato da tempo ci lascia
e poco dopo all'improvviso mia mamma lo
segue prendo un sacco di decisioni
sbagliate e perdo tutti i miei soldi e
mi ritrovo anche pieno di debiti arrivo
a perdere anche la casa che avevo
regalato i miei genitori e poi se tutto
questo non bastasse scoppia anche una
pandemia globale e che succede a questo
punto succede una cosa abbastanza
incredibile che mi ritrovo felice come
non sono mai stato prima in vita mia
ma com'è possibile cioè non ho neanche i
soldi per fare la spesa
neanche per comprarmi quel panino col
prosciutto crudo per intenderci
e allora come faccio ad essere così in
pace con me stesso così sereno e qui per
provare a capirci qualcosa di più
dobbiamo fare un altro salto e questa
volta addirittura fino in giappone
leggere è sempre stata la mia grande
passione ve l'ho già detto una passione
che non mi ha mai abbandonato nemmeno
nei momenti peggiori
e proprio in uno di questi momenti
dentro a un libro che aveva regalato mia
moglie che parlava di tutt'altro
faccio una scoperta importante le 10 con
e del bue non so se sapete che cosa sono
io non lo sapevo io ho cominciato a
studiare tutto quello che c'era
e così ho scoperto che queste 10 con e
rappresentano un cammino zen verso
l'illuminazione verso la felicità e
queste icone hanno cominciato ad
ossessionarmi arrivo a stamparle e ad
attenderle su una parete e ogni sera
mentre mi lavo i denti le fisso in
attesa di una qualche risposta e
comincia a pensare che forse c'è un
parallelismo tra queste 10 icone e la
montagna delle storie che abbiamo visto
poco fa è in effetti le cose tornano
almeno per le prime cinque icone infatti
anche qui abbiamo qualcuno che sta nel
suo mondo ordinario
poi l'incidente scatenante succede
qualcosa vede le tracce del bue e poi
decide di entrare in questo mondo
sconosciuto alla ricerca di questo boom
lo trova combatte e finalmente arriva al
meet point alla falsa vittoria in quel
momento riesce a catturare il bue ma qui
finisce il parallelismo
perché come vedete dopo il meet point
nel momento in cui cominciano i calci
dove dovremmo ruzzolare giù per la
montagna invece le icone continuano
vanno verso l'alto
e così ogni sera continuavo a fissare
queste icone mentre mi lavo i denti e
continuavo ad aspettare questa
illuminazione e alla fine dopo molto
tempo è arrivata e la verità è questa è
che mentre la nostra vita ci prende a
calci in faccia mentre scendiamo verso
il punto di morte in realtà stiamo
andando verso l'alto stiamo crescendo
perché questi calci ci stanno facendo
capire da che parte sta la felicità
tutte queste prove ci stanno insegnando
dove la vera felicità già e dove dentro
di noi
inutile cercarla fuori inutile nel mio
caso inseguire successo e soldi per
placare quella ferita di quel bambino
che voleva quel panino con il prosciutto
crudo e questa verità che la felicità è
dentro di noi
me ne rendo conto è banale ed è
irricevibile a livello nazionale e
questo perché perché noi siamo stati
abituati sin da piccoli a cercare di
arrivare ottenere costruire tutto fuori
da noi costruire costruire costruire e
solo dopo aver costruito per molto tempo
finalmente saremmo arrivati alla
felicità beh non è così ci insegnano a
girare il mondo inutilmente quando tutto
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno è a meno
di un centimetro da noi a questo punto
immagino che vi starete chiedendo ma
quindi per andare incontro la felicità
dobbiamo aspettare di prendere una serie
di calci in faccia dalla vita beh no non
dovrebbe essere così se solo qualcuno ci
insegnasse due piccole cose la prima che
la felicità esiste e la seconda che
dobbiamo cercarla dentro di noi e non
fuori
se ignoriamo queste due verità allora sì
la vita si impegna per prenderci a calci
in faccia e farci andare verso quella
direzione
allora arrivato a questo punto mi sono
chiesto due cose che cosa sarebbe stato
di quel bambino di 8 anni che ero
se avessi saputo questa verità e cosa
sarebbe stato di quel 3
n che pensava di avere tutto ma alla
fine la mattina si svegliava e vomitava
e così ho cominciato a ragionare
possibile che tutte le azioni che
facciamo nella nostra vita mirino alla
felicità cioè letteralmente l'obiettivo
unico di tutti gli abitanti del pianeta
ma a scuola questa non è la materia
principale insegnamento non vi sembra un
paradosso
e allora partendo da questo ragionamento
cominciato a studiare e ho scoperto un
sacco di cose ad esempio che tutto
quello che i bambini imparano da 0 a 7
anni rimarrà con loro per sempre per
tutta la loro vita e ho scoperto anche
che a scuola oggi si studiano materie
per lavori che fra dieci anni non
esisteranno più
e ancora ho scoperto che le skills più
importanti nel futuro dei giovani
saranno creatività curiosità ed empatia
più andavo avanti e più mi rendevo conto
che probabilmente la scuola di oggi non
ti insegna le materie giuste per provare
a vivere bene e allora mi sono chiesto
pensa se esistesse una scuola che sin da
piccolissimo ti insegna ad essere felice
e che magari ti insegna a raccontare una
storia e che ti insegna che cos'è la
creatività la compassione
l'empatia la gratitudine la noia logic
tutte materie fondamentali al giorno
d'oggi in un mondo in continuo
cambiamento
e queste materie non devono andare a
sostituire quelle esistenti ma devono
semplicemente integrare il piano di
studi e poi i ragionamenti non si sono
fermati qui perché poi ho pensato
pensa se all'inizio questa scuola fosse
online e in tutte le lingue del mondo e
soprattutto gratuita e poi ho continuato
e ho pensato ci saranno dei moduli da
poter distribuire a tutte le scuole
esistenti e ancora dopo questo punto
forse avremo la prima scuola fisica e
poi la seconda e poi la terza e chissà e
poi al culmine di tutti questi
ragionamenti una piccola folgorazione ma
se fossi io a provare ad aprirla questa
scuola se fosse questo il terzo atto
della mia vita
beh non ho risposte anzi ho solo un
sacco di domande però ho anche tanta
voglia di studiare e ricercare girare il
mondo per trovare questi maestri i
migliori possibili per insegnare queste
materie e per dare vita a questo
progetto
ripeto non ho risposte solo tantissime
domande però ho una consapevolezza che
la mattina mi sveglio e non vomito più
adesso non ho più paura di dire di dirmi
che sono felice sì lo so probabilmente
la felicità non si può insegnare quello
che possiamo fare forse e provare ad
indicare una via un sentiero che ti
porta magari dove c'è qualche
probabilità in più di trovarla grazie e
siate felici
[Musica]